hello everyone after the GE Advanced
results are out and the josa counseling
starts students are often faced with a
number of difficult choices and
questions
like whether to go for a non-surgical
Branch meaning a department like
mechanical civil chemical Aerospace
Metallurgy in an older IIT
or to go for a circuitable branch like
the computer science and engineering
department the electrical engineering
department or the electronics department
in a newer IIT similarly the question
can take the form of going for a
non-surgical branch
in in IIT versus a circle branch in an
nit or some other form or some other
variant of these questions so the nature
of the questions is such that it is not
possible to give a direct answer to it
anybody who pretends to give a direct
answer to these questions is actually
lying to you okay so because of the
individual nature of these questions
what I'm going to do in this video is
that I'm going to present to you certain
facts and certain important
considerations with the help of which
you can come to an informed decision in
facing these questions and go forward
with your Joseph counseling choices so
uh let us address these questions one by
one uh please note that sometimes it
also happens that students are also
confused a little bit about the
emotional nature of uh of a certain
question like whether to
sacrifice a seat in an IIT for
a more desirable branch in some other
Institute with the emotional notion
being that after so much hard work being
invested 4J Advanced when they are
finally getting some seat in IIT should
they sacrifice it there is that extreme
emotional component to it so in this
video I'll try to uh
somehow present some discussion
regarding that also
so first of all some of the direct
questions uh
how to go about considering and thinking
about those so uh
the first first and foremost thing which
you have to understand and ask yourself
is what is your desire this is very very
important if you identify for yourself
and when I say identify I mean that
really really isolate for yourself in a
very concentrated fashion what is your
desire and not being swayed by what the
media hype is telling you or what any
other influencer so to speak is telling
you so you ask yourself what is your
desire whether you really want to go for
a certain Department if that desire is
strong enough I would say that listen to
that
the uh the the logic behind this is see
if you go to a department which you
really really desire to study in a
reasonably good Institute maybe it is
not your dream Institute
it is most likely going to be the case
that you are going to enjoy studying it
now it may also so happen that down the
line maybe after uh three or four
semesters of study it may happen that
you absolutely do not love it okay it's
not that you dislike studying the
department it may turn out to be like
that because once you get into the
nitty-gritty details of a of a certain
departmental coursework it may turn out
that the kind of expectation you had of
that department it is not true but at
the end of the day what will happen is
that you will be satisfied with the fact
that you had taken the decision yourself
and not by listening to anybody else
whether it was your parents or God
forbid some kind of coaching Institute
person
okay so when when such a thing happens
that even if you're a little bit unhappy
with your department but you know for a
fact that it is it was your choice to
begin with
uh
my understanding uh of from whatever I
have seen of students is that
they would maybe a little bit unhappy
but they will not get depressed about it
they will not blame anybody else for it
that just what what could possibly have
happened if they had not listened to
that uh to such and such in person and
maybe just listen to their heart at
least that satisfaction will be there
that you listen to your heart and went
forward with it okay there is this is
very much an important part of being an
adult that you take a decision you stick
to it and you also face the consequences
of that decision
okay
the next point is that this is this is
relatively rare when students have that
strong a desire that that they go
against the grain and choose some
department on their own the more common
scenario is that students are not at all
sure about what they want okay they
don't even know what their desire is
so in this kind of a situation there is
a great temptation to just go to close
your eyes and just go for the more
famous Institute I would say this would
be a very big mistake so pause a little
bit if you're in this stage and do a
little bit of research on your own I've
already mentioned this in a similar
video regarding josa counseling I had
made in the previous year but I would
like to emphasize it here even more that
if you're in this kind of a scenario
please go to the website of the
different the websites of the different
departments in any good Institute
whether it is the iits the nits most of
us have our course curriculum posted on
our websites you go to these websites
and just check the curriculum
okay and you may be pleasantly surprised
by what you find in the different
departments why I'm saying this is that
it is my common experience that students
often have a misunderstanding a
misconception a very very strong
misconception about certain departments
most common example is the chemical
engineering department okay and myself
not from chemical engineering but this
is this is usually quite common people
think that chemical engineering has a
lot of lot to do with chemistry that is
not true of course there is a little bit
of chemistry there's a little bit of
chemistry in every Department maybe a
little bit more in chemical engineering
but there's a lot and lot of physics
there's a lot more physics and chemical
engineering then there is chemistry okay
people do not realize it and there's a
lot of mathematical modeling involved
there's a lot of experimental work
involved which is ultimately physics
based okay so people do not realize this
they just hear the word chemical and
they get swayed by it and they never
fill this choice so I would suggest
strongly that you please go to the
Department
of the different
uh of the different the website of the
different departments and make an
informed decision learn try to try to
find out what they're teaching
uh similarly in mechanical engineering
it is not only about mechanics there's a
lot of thermodynamics there's a lot of
food mechanics uh there's a lot of
manufacturing which you probably do not
have any exposure to in your plus two
studies
a furthermore I would still I would like
to point out that computer science
everyone's dream Department uh many
people just blindly if they have a good
enough rank they blindly go for computer
science without realizing that computer
science is not only about programming
okay it also sometimes happens that
students have been exposed to some kind
of programming experience in school and
based on that if there have been if they
have been if they found some interest in
programming they just go for it uh
thinking that kabulous sense will be all
about it
computer science C so the computer
science and engineering department the
computer science part especially will
have a lot of maths okay and the maths
that will not be the calculus kind of
maths rather it will be the pure match
kind of match so combinatorial maths
where you will have to be really strong
in things uh involving permutations and
combinations probability uh discrete
mathematics uh these sources this sort
of things and not everyone's brain is
attuned for that kind of thinking it may
be very much possible that a student who
has not managed to get a high enough
rank uh may be very good in those kinds
of things and a student who had gotten
very high rank in J Advanced may not
actually be very properly suitable for
that kind of a thing so you have to make
an informed decision
there's also the flip side to it that uh
it's it's quite is rather interesting
that and this I'm telling from an
experience that I had with one of my
juniors he was in the computer science
department eventually he did very very
well in computer science engineering he
went on to his PhD uh
he told me he and naturally I mean he he
had a very high rank he was in the
computer science engineering department
of ID kharipur so you can understand
he told me that and his friends also
told me that he was not particularly
strong in mechanics so had he been in
mechanical engineering
he would not have
been able to perform that well
okay so everyone's mind is not attuned
similarly
okay so it is extremely important that
you sync up your desire your abilities
and with what you really want uh going
into your undergraduate studies but even
after all these considerations you find
that you are still not sure okay it
could happen that you are still not sure
about what you really desired which
department you want to choose
you may still be tempted to just go for
a higher ranked Institute understandably
so but my advice here is that Please
Please be aware of the fact that if you
happen to choose a an Institute
sort of dream Institute for you just by
going into some random department where
you absolutely do not have any
interest in studying
you will be absolutely trapped you will
feel trapped uh for the next four or
five years
and please please do not commit this
mistake of uh of consoling yourself that
you will joins a department and then
hopefully at the end of the first year
you will go for a department change
there have been innumerable such cases
where people have come with that hope
and then unable to change the department
they have actually gotten trapped in
that department where they did not have
any intention of studying okay so this
is a very very sad scenario
please please do not fall into this trap
of the hope of a department change if it
happens great
okay if it happens absolutely great but
please please do not make your choice
based on that hope it is much better
that you sacrifice the the dream of
going to a particular Institute and
choose some other Institute where you
get a department which you reasonably
want to have have some have some desire
of studying I would also like to point
out one very important fact which people
uh which students at your age sometimes
do not understand across the different
iits and the nits and a lot of the other
colleges also
the nature of the syllabus is quite
common
the textbooks are mostly similar the
curriculum is mostly similar the time
that you have that will have because
they are all semester-based systems uh
in each semester to study these subjects
they're also more or less the same okay
so if you're going into if the choice is
between a very famous Institute and a in
not as famous as an Institute if it is a
at least an old classical Institute
properly established one and it has
proper facilities
there will be absolutely not much
difference between
the kind of education that you will
receive
however there are certain subtleties to
consider okay and this is where I
believe the emotional part of people
come into play a lot of the emotions of
students is invested with the dream of
uh getting a seat in IIT
now
in many of the videos that you will find
on YouTube
many people mention that
iits are what they are
not because just of the name or the name
of the iits is actually because of the
students and there is a certain truth in
it because uh
over and over the years where uh the
kind of students who enter these
institutes are extremely competitive
extremely ambitious
driven and they are living together in
this uh highly competitive environment
they kind of learn from each other
through their group activities through
the various societies beyond the
classrooms and that's how this high
quality culture comes into play there is
absolute truth in it
but at the same time you have to
understand that uh
it's not that just because a group of
students are coming to IIT this
culture will be there only in the iits
in some of the top notch nit is also
some of the newer ni iits also this kind
of a culture does exist
okay so this this may be some kind of
programming culture or maybe a culture
of ah
participating in open source projects or
some kind of Aviation clubs or maybe in
some kind of non-technical things also
there will be lots and lots of
activities
so you can very much be a a part of a
high quality academic and non-academic
culture beyond the
classrooms in the in in in in in places
which are not iits also
but then why is why do people still keep
on taking the names of the iits so much
is there something extra there
well if you think about only the
undergraduate level uh maybe there is it
is debatable
okay
but I would say and this is my very
personal opinion what really
distinguishes the iits and certainly
iisc
is that uh what happens beyond the
undergraduates or in the transition
between the undergraduate and the higher
level studies because you see uh some of
the most are driven uh some very
experienced faculty are present in the
iits it is a fact okay the selection
procedure of the faculties themselves
and the iits is extremely extremely
rigorous
so what happens is that if a student
is actually academically oriented he
will get an opportunity to work with
some very experienced faculty in areas
of research which are absolutely Cutting
Edge this is this is this can be very
very exciting this can be very very
fulfilling and this can give a very
unique experience to the student which
can be a great launching pad for a
carrier in higher studies in Academia
and research so this was on the research
side on the teaching side also which
probably does not get too much mention
by any media but I know for a fact
because I have been a student in an IIT
I have been a teacher for quite a few
years now uh
you see my feeling is that there are
some really really dedicated teachers in
the iits I'm not saying that such kind
of teachers do not exist in the nits but
my personal opinion is that in the iits
there are some really really good
teachers I'd like to give a very simple
example here
you take up any topic about which you do
not know anything
Okay so
when you try to learn anything about
that topic definitely you are going to
pick up to three textbooks maybe you're
going to watch a few videos
I also have to do certain things like
this that even at this age especially
when I am involved in some kind of
interdisciplinary research so starting
from the very basic level I want to get
up to speed on that topic so I also try
to learn like that but I have found out
that no matter how much I study how much
I try to collect information from the
various sources textbooks videos Etc if
I happen to talk to a colleague and I
had another IIT faculty just for about
half an hour or one hour the kind of
information that I can actually learn
from them is just unparalleled and uh
students who are at the IIT is probably
they do not realize this when they are
learning from such kind of teachers in
the classroom they are not just getting
as part of the the syllabus which is
definitely common across the different
institutes just the things which may be
written in one single textbook the kind
of things that they are learning is
collected and collated from a number of
different sources Plus in addition to
that the teachers are putting in they
are pouring into it their research
experiences in those topics
okay sometimes and and quite a few times
actually they are going and extending
the things which are beyond the
textbooks and I'm not just saying here
that they they mention some some Cutting
Edge research as some kind of an
advertisement for the topic uh or some
kind of a motivation I'm actually saying
some hardcore things which will not be
found in any textbook but because they
have done hardcore research in that they
know how to present some new kind of
things uh in in these topics so you will
definitely have that Advantage also so
if someone is really really academically
interested wishes to to become an
academician then yes
I believe uh coming to iits will make a
difference but if it is just a job that
you want at the end of the day then
maybe uh go for some other kind of
considerations also
so these are the broad points I wanted
to discuss uh I'm sure there will be
many other uh confusing questions I
welcome you all to uh to write them down
in the comments I'll try my best to
answer them and if I find there are some
important some rather important points
which I have not discussed in this video
then maybe I'll try to make another
video uh to display some of the wrong
Notions and maybe discuss some other
important considerations so with all
this uh I'll thank you and I'll wish you
all the very best in your in in taking
an informed Choice uh in your josa
counseling thank you very much all the
very best